the ever-changing cast of House of the
dragon can be hard to pin down so here's
the handy guide to all the new Targaryen
Offspring blonde and otherwise thanks to
a 10-year time jump in the sixth episode
entitled The Princess and the queen a
big chunk of the cast is now all grown
up and they've all got kids of their own
oh you are nearly a man-grown how is it
that you can be so short-sighted
considering that house of the Dragon has
already been renewed for a second season
and Promises to bring viewers through
the entirety of the Targaryen civil war
known as the dance of the Dragons these
kids will with absolute certainty play
enormous roles in the infighting to come
that said it can be tough to parse which
children belong to whom or how and why
they might even be important so who are
the Targaryen offspring that we need to
know about and why do they matter This
Is The Stuff Lino as the sixth episode
kicks off Rainier is deep in the throes
of childbirth with her third son whom
her husband surprised Kristen's Joffrey
after his dead love ever but the ones
who really matter right now are jaceris
and Luke Harris AKA Jace and Luke
introduced when they meet their baby
brother there's one thing instantly
noticeable about these two boys they
don't have platinum blonde hair while
their parents born of houses Targaryen
and valarian definitely do anyone who
remembers Ned Stark muttering Baratheon
black of hair in the first season of
Game of Thrones probably knows where
this storyline is going turns out
considering Lenor well doesn't bat for
Rainier's team she outsourced her
child-bearing years to Sir Harwin strong
captain of the city watch and a
confirmed brunette
do you keep trying Selena
soon I'll let you make it when it looks
like you
all that said Rainier's children are
definitely targaryens in the episode
jacaris works on training his Dragon
Vermax who's quite young but is already
responding well to his commands lucaris
is still quite young but it's mentioned
that his traditional Targaryen dragon
egg hatched in his crib as well so it
stands to reason that both brothers will
be on Dragon back soon enough far away
from their cousins in King's Landing
Bella and Rayna who seem to be named for
their Targaryen ancestor Balon as well
as Lena's mother rhaenice are stranded
with their parents Elena valarian and
Prince Damon Targaryen though they lead
a seemingly peaceful and bountiful life
out in pentos the girls dream of more in
one scene in The Princess and the queen
Reyna laments not having a dragon egg
from birth as her sister Bella does
while Elena reassures her that she'll go
on to be a writer someday however these
two young girls are struck by tragedy
when their mother Elena in labor with
their younger brother encounters
complications that can't be overcome I
preached the limit of my art
Lena opts to burn herself and the
burgeoning baby alive with the help of
her Dragon vegar leaving her daughters
alone with their father Damon these two
girls may be motherless but they have
Valerian and Targaryen blood in their
veins unlike Rainier's children the
blondest children on the show thus far
aegon II
aymond and Helena are the issue of
Allison and her much older husband
Rainier's father King viserys blessed
with the icy hair of the Targaryen
family their parentage doesn't stand in
doubt for a second and upon aegon's
birth there's a bit of a kerfuffle over
the line of succession despite
previously naming rhaenyra as His
official Heir aegon's mere existence
places King viserys in a bind the Seven
Kingdoms may not accept a female ruler
and with a male Heir at long last it
might make more sense to put aegon on
the throne viseris sticks by his
daughter but as he ages it's clear that
his wife has other plans The Princess
and the queen is the first Glimpse
weekend of aegon as an older child and
honestly he's kind of a jerk he bullies
his younger brother Eamonn by giving him
a pig instead of a dragon and fights
dirty during his training showing
himself to be pretty smug and largely
insufferable by contrast Eamon and
Helena have shown themselves to be much
quieter Helena seems to like playing
with centipedes well or amend just wants
to follow in his family's massive
footsteps
[Music]